RAHUL TELANG: So
thank you so much.
Thank you, Hal,
for the kind words.
Thank you, Cliff and David,
for inviting us and hosting us
and organizing this.
Thank you all for coming
and spending your afternoon.
We are honored and excited to
be part of this conversation
and look forward to your
comments and your feedback.
This book, at some
level, is a summary
of some of the research agenda
that Michael and I have pursued
over the last 10, 15 years.
And, in all honesty,
some of that research
was also supported
and funded by Google.
So thank you all around.
Appreciate it very much.
So we decided that maybe
we'll talk for about 30,
35 minutes, and then open
the floor for some discussion
and some questions.
So I'll take the first half.
Michael will speak
in the second half.
And then he also agreed that
any difficult questions,
he'll be more than
happy to tackle.
So let me start with a story
that we also have in the book.
Many of you might
have read this book,
would have seen the movie
"The Perfect Storm."
And the idea behind the book
was there were this, I think,
six seamen who were
trying to get to the land
as quickly as possible because
they had a valuable catch.
The only trouble was to
get to the route that
was the quickest
to the land also
had turbulent weather
and potential storms.
But the crew thought
that they have experience
dealing with such
storms and they
would be able to survive this.
So they decided to take
that particular route.
But they underestimated
the risk.
And what happens is they
ran into not just one storm,
but confluence of storms.
That's why they titled
"The Perfect Storm."
And, unfortunately,
they perished.
What we believe that in
the entertainment industry,
similar technological
turbulence and disruptions
are taking place.
And unless and until
the traditional firms
are able to adapt and
change their business model,
they're going to be at a
significant competitive
disadvantage.
And when I say
entertainment industry,
predominantly we'll discuss the
publishing industry, the music
industry, the television and
the motion picture industry.
And I'm going to talk
a little bit about what
are some of the major
technological changes
that are taking place.
But before I go there, I wanted
to spend a little bit of time
going back in
history and arguing
that this industry pretty
much has been dominated
by a very few players.
If you look at the
history of 100 years--
whether it's
publishing, whether it's
motion picture, whether
it's music industry--
a few firms have essentially
dominated this industry
for a long period of time.
And sometimes the very same
firms that have dominated.
And you wonder, what is
it about the industry,
or what is it about the firms,
that gives them that advantage
to continue to acquire and
have a large market share?
So one of the most
important assets
you needed to have if you
were in this industry,
if you were one of
these firms, was
that you needed scale and size.
And why did you
need scale and size?
For the simple reason that
one of the core functions
many of these firms perform
was to basically find
the talent, hopefully predict
that some of that talent
is going to be turned
into stars or superstars--
so whether you are a music label
or whether you're a publisher,
you're trying to find that
author or you're trying
to find that artist who is
going to become successful.
Unfortunately, to be able
to make that prediction,
to be able to figure out who
is going to be that next star
was unscientific at best.
There was very little data.
There was very little
analysis that one
could do to figure out.
You could have some
information, but broadly it
was difficult to say who
is going to be successful
and who is going to fail.
And most of the artists,
or most of the authors,
of most of the scripts
probably turn out
to be not all that
much successful.
In fact, a very few, a
handful, of the projects
actually became very successful.
So, naturally, the
one business principle
was to follow the gut feel or
follow your superior instincts
to identify the
potential talent and then
get it to the mass audience.
There was a very
nice quote, actually,
by William Goldman who said
that nobody knows anything.
In the motion picture
industry, everything
was basically a guess.
And if you're lucky,
that's an educated guess.
So that was how, more or
less, some of the processes
in the industry worked.
And beyond, then, finding
the talent, the second job
that the firm needed
to do was to get it
in front of the audience,
basically convince
the audience in the mass
market that you actually
have a superstar waiting.
So now you have a majority of
the projects likely to fail.
So you needed scale and size
to support a slew of projects
so a few of them turn out
to be very successful.
And then you needed power to
be able to very aggressively
campaign for that star, for
that artist, for that movie.
So you needed to
influence a radio station
to play your artist's songs so
that people can listen to that.
Or, in a physical store, where
there was a limited shelf
space, you needed power to be
able to convince that retailer
to stock your item and
prominently display it
and so on and so forth so
that people can know about it.
Again, the firm who had
the scale and the size
and the stable of successful
stars were able to do it.
If you were a small
independent firm,
it was tough to compete against
that model on both sides
where you needed scale and size.
So, naturally, if you are a
budding artist or an author
or a script writer,
you probably felt
that going with the big firms
was the ticket to success
because they had these
natural advantages.
The third thing they
also did and they
had going for them was
that they could control
their content where they
could-- what we call usually
is that apply some of the
product discrimination
strategy.
So what they could do was sell
the same or similar product
at different times to different
people in different channels
and be able to monetize the
product over its lifetime.
So, for example, if you are in
the motion picture industry,
the movie will
release in a theater,
then it will go on
the DVD, then it
will go into the
pay-per-view, then
it'll go into the HBO window
over there, so on and so forth.
And all of these formats
allow you to both expand
your market-- so more and
more people can watch--
and sometimes
actually allowed you
to sell the similar
product multiple times
to the same user.
So you watch the movie in
theater, you also got the DVD,
and you might have watched
the movie back on the TV.
So once you have all
of these three going--
which is you could control
the supply of talent,
you could control
the distribution,
and you could control how
the content was flowing
through various channels--
you had a very successful
and a robust business model.
And this particular model
worked for a very long time.
In fact, it worked so well
that most of these forms
were highly successful
and profitable.
And one of the senior
executives actually
came to one of our classes,
and he was very confident,
saying, look, we
have been successful
for the last 100 years.
We know how to
create the content.
And there is no
reason why we will not
continue to be successful in
the foreseeable future as well.
Look at our business model.
So what are the
technology disruptions
we believe have been taking
place over the last 10
or 15 years that we
believe are eroding
some of these advantages
that the firm has?
The first is the
internet and broadband.
It might seem trivial, but
the internet and broadband
had this enormous impact.
Some of that impact came through
that the internet basically
spawned enormous amount of
online piracy and infringement
of content.
In fact, if you go back and
look at the music industry,
you could literally
split the music industry
into two periods, before
Napster and after Napster.
That's the kind of impact
the Napsters of this world
had on the industry.
So going beyond the
fact that piracy
had a very large negative
effect on the firms' ability
to monetize, it actually
had a large effect
on their windowing strategy and
how they released the product.
Now it was very hard to
wait and release the product
in the international
market a month later
because piracy ate
into that revenue.
It became harder for
you to delay the product
in one channel versus
the other channel
because, again, people
found it easier to then go
and essentially infringe.
So your ability to monetize the
lifecycle of the product, which
was a very valuable source
of revenues for some
of these quote, unquote
"catalog titles,"
became much more challenging
when the internet and broadband
came about and started
cutting into your ability
to control the content.
This is a very quick
example I'll give.
This was an example of
how this control got
eroded a little bit.
This was a dispute NBC
had with Apple iTunes.
And NBC decided
that they were going
to take all the content
away from iTunes in the hope
that maybe they will be able
to exert some power on Apple
to sign a more favorable deal.
Basically what
happened is as soon
as NBC took the content
away from Apple,
people started flocking
to BitTorrent network
and started downloading
what was available
legally now from the
piracy network, again,
suggesting that your
ability to then negotiate
with different
channels got severely
eroded because the
piracy came about
and people found it
much easier, then,
to get the content from
sources if you didn't make it
available on the legal channel.
The second thing
that happened was,
then, the digitization
meant that there
were revolution where the
cost of producing content
fell very significantly.
So now you can write a book,
you can record music, or even
shoot a movie at
a fraction of cost
than what was possible earlier.
And then you had this bunch
of platforms like the YouTubes
and Facebook and what have
you that made it much cheaper
for people to actually
get their product
and get their content in
front of the mass audience.
So, at some level, the big
companies, the major players,
in the industry did two things.
They identified the talent.
And the got the talent
to the mass market.
And now you had the
technology changes happening,
which made the role of a
gatekeeper for these firms,
again, got eroded because many
people started bypassing them
and said we can directly go.
It doesn't happen all the
time, but for many artists
it's much easier to do.
That again meant that
their ability to negotiate
with artists and authors
and script writers
and what have you
was, again, eroded
because of these digitisation.
So we give many
examples in the book.
Here are all of the different
players who actually bypassed,
to an extent, that
traditional players, and on
their own right, actually
became very successful.
So Amanda Hocking became a
very popular author just doing
self-publishing.
Lindsey Stirling, who
is a hip-hop violinist
and musician-- the
music label thought
that she doesn't fit into any
traditional categorization.
She became a YouTube sensation.
"Fifty Shades of Gray,"
probably all of you know,
it's a blockbuster, but actually
it was a very obscure book.
It was a self-published
book and totally relied
on viral marketing
to get its name out.
And obviously, now it's a
multimillion dollar product.
Or Neelesh Misra, who runs
a radio show in India which
is completely crowd-sourced.
So he sources all these movies.
People submit the stories.
Everything gets outsourced
and crowd-sourced.
And he runs a very,
very popular show.
In all of these
examples, what you see
is that the middlemen,
or the gatekeepers,
or their ability to exercise
power got eroded a little bit.
And finally, what we
had was the growth
of these online
platforms-- the Amazons,
the Netflix, the YouTubes,
and the Googles of this world.
They did not have a
limited shelf space.
So Amazon could stock
hundreds and thousands
of books or movies
or music titles.
And they also
realized that to be
able to satisfy
their customer, they
needed to use the information
they're collecting
from their consumers to
offer appropriate and correct
recommendations to
delight its consumers.
So it started using
enormous amount of data
to make that appropriate
recommendations.
So on one hand, we
had the major players
who did content curation.
So they decided
which content was
going to go in
front of the public
and controlled the content.
And on the other hand, we had
the online platform that said,
I'm not going to do
content curation.
Every content is
available on my platform.
But I will make it easy.
I will make it
easy for consumers
to find what they actually like.
So I'll offer them what I
believe that the consumer might
be interested in.
So, again, some of the
power started shifting
toward these online players.
Obviously, I don't
have to convince you
that the Amazons and
Netflix are-- their scale
and size is also much bigger.
Netflix operates in 80
different countries.
Amazon has a very
large footprint.
So now they have
this enormous power
in deciding how to
price the product,
how to promote the product,
how to recommend the product
to the end user, again, means
that they have a lot more
negotiating power
when they're getting
the content from the
content creators,
whether it's music or movies
and so on and so forth.
Now all of this
still would have been
fine except that some
of these companies
then decided that they actually
want to now go into the content
production.
So the Netflix of the word
then decided that, look,
I have deep pockets.
We have this enormous amount of
customer data and a very large
customer base.
Why not?
I can hire the talent which
can create the content.
And I will become a
vertically integrated company,
from creating the
content to distributing
and promoting and advertising
the content to my consumer
base.
And this is one of
the biggest important
and a competitive threat
to the existing players.
And now Michael is going to
talk about the way Netflix goes
about creating the content
is very different than how
the traditional players have
generally created the content.
And one more element being
that all of these companies,
they basically make
decisions based
on data rather than on
gut feel or on instincts.
They have a large consumer base.
They have enormous amount of
data about what consumer does,
what consumer doesn't do,
what are their preferences.
They hire the people who have
the skills to actually use
that data.
And based on that
combination, now they
are going in the market
and saying, I can actually
do better than some of
these traditional firms
potentially can do.
I have the financial
wherewithal.
I have this enormous consumer
base that's loyal to me.
And this is, really,
at some level,
we are talking about
the perfect storm
that the traditional
players are facing.
So Michael is going
to probably talk
about how they're using it.
MICHAEL SMITH: Thanks, Rahul.
So I would argue, if this
were a traditional industry,
we could stop right
here and go directly
to what they should do.
I think there's
a strong argument
you can make that technology
is changing the source of power
in this industry.
Let's talk about what
the industry should do.
I would argue that
entertainment is not
a typical industry in
the sense that they're
very interested in
the second question.
Will technological
change actually
damage my ability to
make great content?
And you might disagree
with me about this,
but I think this
question, in many ways,
is every bit as important
to the traditional industry
as the first question is.
I think if you
were to say, here's
a technology that's going to
allow you to make more money,
but it's going to
significantly damage
the quality of storytelling,
they'd probably
say, hey, you know what?
We'll just stick
with what we've got.
So let me tell a story
about why this might damage
the quality of storytelling.
A few years ago, I was
sitting with Monte,
and we were getting ready
to watch "House of Cards"
on Netflix.
We were on our favorite couch.
I'd turned off the lights.
And we start the show.
If you've seen the first
episode of "House of Cards,"
you know it starts with
a black screen, and then
the sound of screeching tires,
and then a collision, and then
a whimpering dog.
And at this point, Kevin
Spacey's character,
Senator Frank Underwood,
comes out of his house
and approaches the
scene of the accident.
Now Monte was clearly
nervous at this point.
He was huddled up all the way
at the other end of the couch
and looking very uncomfortable.
But I figured
everything's going to be.
As the lead character,
Frank Underwood's
going to do what lead characters
always do when you introduce
them to the audience.
He's going to perform some noble
act to endear himself to us,
like saving or protecting
the injured dog.
So Frank Underwood
does something
completely unexpected.
He approaches the dog.
And then he speaks
directly to the camera.
And he leans down and
strangles the animal.
So this was too much.
I had to turn off the show.
I had to turn back on the
lights so I wouldn't severely
scar my friend Monte.
Now why might this be
bad for entertainment?
After all, ever since
we've had televisions,
people have been turning them
off for all sorts of reasons.
The reason this might
be bad for entertainment
is that now Netflix knows
exactly when Monte and I turned
off the show.
And the fear is they might
combine that with information
about when millions of other
viewers turned off their shows
and use that to start to use
data and algorithms to make
creative decisions.
Makes sense?
So that's the concern.
And that's the real
motivation for why
we wanted to include the answer
to this question in the book,
is a lot of people are worried
that technological change is
going to damage the
quality of entertainment.
While we were writing the
book, we learned an awful lot
about this question and an
awful lot about the industry.
The first thing we learned
is that writing a book
is really hard.
This was our first book.
As academics, we feel
pretty comfortable writing
30-page papers.
So when we sat down with
our editor at MIT Press,
and she said the
book ought to be 200,
maybe 250 pages long, Rahul
and I looked at each other.
We did the math,
and we said, sounds
like if we write seven 30-page
papers, we ought to be done.
How hard could that be?
And the answer is,
you're an idiot.
Writing a book is nothing like
writing seven different papers.
The reason it's different
is that your publisher
expects you to tell a story.
And storytelling is
just incredibly hard.
And I think the
painful realization
of just how difficult
storytelling
is gave me and Rahul a
much deeper appreciation
for the many talented
storytellers in the publishing,
music, and movie
businesses, and for how much
we all benefit from
the work they do.
But I think also
a renewed passion
for understanding
whether technology
might be damaging their
ability to bring great stories
to the audience.
And many of our
friends in the industry
are worried that it
will, and not just
because using data
and algorithms
to make creative
decisions could be
bad for the quality of content.
They're also worried that
the new data driven platforms
are just making too much
content in the first place.
So in recent years,
we've seen an explosion
in new creative output, much
of it coming from Silicon
Valley, not Hollywood.
Think "Orange is the New
Black," "Transparent,"
or my new favorite,
"Stranger Things."
And things in this
industry, I would argue,
just keep getting stranger.
In the past year,
Netflix announced
that it was tripling its
output of original programming.
Amazon announced
that they were going
to start to produce 12 movies
per year for their platform.
And this little company called
Google announced YouTube Red
with plans for 10 original
movies of their own.
Carleton Cuse, the Emmy
award-winning showrunner,
argued that this is going
to be bad for the quality
of entertainment.
And he used a sports analogy.
What he said is this
explosion in new output
is very similar to what would
happen if the NFL suddenly
expanded to have 90 teams.
You have a whole bunch more
football available to you,
but the quality of it would
be significantly diluted.
But if data is going to ruin
the quality of entertainment,
then why are the new
data driven platforms
winning so many awards?
Netflix has taken home
133 Emmy nominations,
including 54 this year alone.
And this past December,
Netflix and Amazon
had more Golden
Globe nominations
than the combined number of
nominations for the top four
broadcast networks.
And it's not just critics
who are happy with what's
going on in Silicon Valley.
Kevin Spacey himself
called his experience
making "House of Cards" the
most fun and most creatively
rewarding experience I've
ever had in front of a camera.
So creativity, it
would seem, is actually
thriving in the hands of these
new data driven providers.
And to understand why, let's
take the advice of Senator
Frank Underwood and
take a step back,
look at the bigger picture.
That's the best Kevin
Spacey I-- anyway.
AUDIENCE: Keep working on it
MICHAEL SMITH: Thank you.
Yeah, don't quit your day job.
All right.
So let's start with the concern
that data driven companies
are going to start using data
to make creative decisions.
This concern is
perfectly reasonable
given how the industry
has always worked.
Prior to Netflix,
greenlighting decisions
were made by a roomful
of industry veterans.
And these experts sat down and
used their years of experience
to estimate how many people
were likely to watch the show.
And then they used their
beliefs about customer behavior
to give the creators notes
about which scenes should
be cut so as to ensure
they retained the audience
and made the best use of
the scarce broadcast slots.
Given how prevalent
this is in the industry,
it's perfectly
reasonable to assume
that Netflix and
Amazon and Google
would use their data to
replicate these processes,
basing greenlighting decisions
on actual audience statistics
and then telling creators
which seems to cut based
on actual audience
behavior instead of notes
about how audiences
were likely to respond.
But taking a step
back, it's clear
that Netflix and
Amazon and you guys
aren't using data to
make creative decisions.
Let's consider the greenlighting
process for a second.
Again, prior to Netflix,
people used industry expertise
to make these decisions.
And a lot of people
in the industry
have concluded that
Netflix was able to see
the potential for
"House of Cards"
before anyone else
in the industry
because Netflix was able
to look into its data
and discover that there were a
lot of fans of Kevin Spacey's
acting, a lot of fans of
David Fincher's directing,
and a lot of fans of the
BBC's "House of Cards."
And that's what gave them
a competitive advantage.
But if you think
about it for a second,
that can't possibly be what gave
them a competitive advantage
because everybody
in the industry
already knew that Kevin
Spacey and David Fincher were
huge hits, and that the
BBC's "House of Cards"
had been a huge success.
The advantage Netflix got
was from using its data
to do something that no
traditional broadcast
network could replicate.
Netflix's advantage
didn't come from knowing
how many fans of Kevin
Spacey were in the audience.
Netflix's advantage came
from knowing exactly who they
were as individuals
and their ability
to promote content
to them directly
based on their
individual preferences.
Netflix's advantage also
changed how content was made.
So let's go back to the first
scene of "House of Cards"
I talked about a second ago.
At the 2014 Aspen
Ideas Festival,
head writer Beau Willimon
said that this scene
was very controversial among
many of the TV veterans
on his creative team.
They said, you can't kill a dog.
You're going to lose half your
viewership in the first 30
seconds.
So apparently Willimon
went to David Fincher
and said, hey man,
are you worried
that we're going to lose
half our audience if we
include this scene?
And Fincher said, I
don't give a shit.
And Willimon said
he didn't either,
so they left the scene in.
That level of
creative freedom would
have been almost unthinkable
in traditional broadcast
television.
On the same Aspen Ideas panel,
Disney veteran Michael Eisner
said that if he had
tried to include
a similarly violent scene
in an episode of broadcast
television, the head of
the network would call me,
the chairman of the
board would call me,
I would be out in 10 minutes.
So the question is why did this
scene work for Netflix, but not
for broadcast television?
The first answer
and the easy one
is that Netflix wasn't pursuing
an advertising-supported
business model.
So it didn't have to worry
about offending advertisers
by including a potentially
controversial scene.
I think the more
profound answer, though,
is that Netflix didn't
face the same scarcity
that traditional
broadcast networks do.
In a traditional
broadcast network,
you can only deliver
one show at a time.
So that show has to appeal to
as many viewers as possible.
But a Netflix subscriber who
was offended by Kevin Spacey's
actions could choose from
thousands of other shows
on Netflix.
And in fact, by watching
how people responded,
you could actually gain
important information
about their preferences.
Monte and I don't like it
when dogs are strangled.
And apparently, Anthony does.
And that's OK.
I'm not judging.
Freak.
[LAUGHTER]
And so this brings us back to
the other concern about data
driven programming,
that too much content
is actually going to be bad
for the creative quality
of the content.
Again, this is a perfectly
reasonable concern given how
the business has always worked.
The business has always
worked sort of like football
in the sense that because the
broadcast slots were limited,
the show with the most
viewers was the winner.
And everybody who subscribes
to Nielsen's rating
knows the score
the next morning.
What we're trying
to argue in the book
is that Netflix and
Amazon and Google
are playing by a completely
different set of rules.
To win, Netflix doesn't
have to find more viewers
to watch their
individual programs.
Netflix wins by finding
more programs that
appeal to the unique
interests and preferences
of their individual viewers.
And that changes everything
about how you measure quality,
we argue.
So, in the end, we argue
Frank Underwood was right.
Power is a lot like real estate.
The closer you
are to the source,
the higher your property values.
The problem for our
friends in Hollywood
is that technology has actually
shifted the source of power
in their industry and
reduced the value of many
of their existing properties.
As Rahul said, for
the last 100 years,
the source of value
in this industry
revolved around being able to
control how content was created
and how content was distributed,
and the scarce resources
associated with how consumers
got access to the content.
What we're trying
to argue in the book
is that in a data driven
world, none of these assets
are as scarce as they once were.
The new scarce resource
is customer attention.
And the new source of
power in this industry
is the ability to understand
detailed information
about my preferences
and then also to control
the platform that allows you
to both collect that data
and deliver content to me
based on my unique preferences.
Make sense?
All right.
So our conclusion
to the question
of is big data hurting the
quality of entertainment
is actually quite the opposite.
Big data is enhancing,
in many ways,
the quality of entertainment
because it gives creators
a much broader palette.
This brings us to
the last point.
All right.
So what does this mean
to us as an audience?
I think what this means is
that big data is actually
going to allow us to
have content that's
going to appeal to exactly
your unique needs based
on your behavior, no
matter who you are.
Now what does this
mean for our friends
in the entertainment industry?
And here, in the
spirit of talking
about how we made
this book, I'll
say the hardest part of
writing this book wasn't
the storytelling,
as hard as that was.
The hardest part of writing
this book was actually
saying something
that we knew was
going to be deeply offensive
to many of our friends
in the entertainment industry.
No one likes to hear that their
business might be in trouble
or that the strategies they've
used for the last 100 years
might need to change.
At the same time, Rahul
and I-- at several points
and using almost exactly these
words-- at several points
while writing the
book, Rahul and I
would come into each
other's offices and say,
are you sure we really
want to say this?
Wouldn't it be easier just
to keep our mouths shut,
mind our own business, and
keep focusing on the research
that we love doing?
Ultimately, we
decided that wasn't
right for a variety of reasons.
Number one, as academics,
we're trained to follow
wherever the data leads.
And in this case,
I think the data
leads to a point of
inflection in the history
of the entertainment industry.
Second, we're fundamentally
committed to the idea
that our friends in the industry
deserve to know the truth.
And so we want to
tell them that.
But I think third, and
maybe most profoundly,
we see this as actually
good news for people
who love great entertainment.
Do you want to
enable storytellers
to tell great unique stories?
On-demand platforms
give you an opportunity
to tell stories
that just wouldn't
be possible in any
traditional broadcast network.
Do you want to help artists
find exactly the right audience
for their content?
Big data gives
you an opportunity
to do that with both a precision
and a profitability that
wouldn't have been possible in
any of your existing channels.
And we're really optimistic
about both the future
of the industry
and also the future
of our friends in Hollywood
to respond to this.
So that's the answer to
the first two questions.
There's a third question
we talk about in the book.
And that is, what can industry
leaders do to respond?
Rahul and I decided not
to answer that question
in this talk in the
hopes that people
would have some reason to go
out and actually buy the book.
So with that, I think we can
turn it over to questions.
Is that what you would
like to do next, sir?
AUDIENCE: I think
you should take
careful note of
Hollywood's response
by increasing the
diversity of their movies.
It used to be it was just
one Marvel comic book
after another.
But now they've
added DC comic books.
MICHAEL SMITH: No comment.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So when we look at the
streaming of music,
we see multiple platforms.
And loosely speaking,
the tendency
is that the platforms have
pretty much everything.
You can find
everything on Spotify.
You can find everything
on YouTube Red.
on Apple Music.
Everything is there.
When you look at movies, you
see a bunch of platforms.
And you can find pretty much
nothing on each of them.
OK, I'm exaggerating, but
there's a very limited set
of movies on Netflix.
There's a very limited set
of musics on each platform.
So why do we see the
difference between music,
where you get everything
at the same place,
and there are multiple
places like that,
and movies, where this is
very much not the case?
And what does the future have
in store, if you can speculate?
MICHAEL SMITH: This
count as a hard question
or an easy question?
RAHUL TELANG: Let me start,
and then you can come fix it.
MICHAEL SMITH: OK.
RAHUL TELANG: So I think
the music definitely
has gone what we call the
subscription-based model.
So industry, actually,
if you talk to them,
they're reasonably
excited that if you're
willing to pay $9.99 a month--
in a year, that turns out
to be about $120-- if they
can get $120 from a consumer
to listen to unlimited music,
they will be reasonably happy.
Of course, the trouble
is to convert people
into paying $9.99 a
month, which is really
the struggle with the
Spotifys and the Apple
Music and everything else.
So the music labels,
then, are willing to work
with the platforms
and say, OK, I
can make my whole
catalog available.
I think for the motion
picture industry,
they still have a lot
of windowing strategies
that go on.
That is, they make a ton
of money selling DVDs,
selling on iTunes, getting
the television audience
as well as in theaters.
If they make this content
available on the Netflix
of the world, I think
they're not sure
how they're going to monetize.
They're not sure
whether that they
want to move in
the business world
where everything
is going to turn
into movie from day
one basically becomes
a subscription-based model.
So, for the motion
picture industry,
I think it's not going to
happen anytime soon, I believe.
MICHAEL SMITH: So A
guess without data,
let's imagine a world
where the heterogeneity
and valuations for movies was
higher than it is for music.
In that world-- and
now I'm going back
to a famous book,
"Information" something.
I can't remember
what it was called.
AUDIENCE: "Information Shared."
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL SMITH: Where you
say bundling is optimal
as long as the variance of
adding a good to the bundle
doesn't increase the variance.
I can imagine a
world where there's
enough heterogeneity in movies
that for a lot of these movies,
adding the movie to the bundle
might increase its variance.
That's one potential
explanation.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I just want
to add something to this.
The characteristic--
MICHAEL SMITH: Since we have
the author of the book here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
the characteristic
that's interesting
is music you want
to hear over and over again.
I love that Norah Jones album.
I want to hear it night
and day for the next month.
Movies you want to see on
an occasional basis with one
exception.
And that is kids movies
where it's just like music.
They want to see it
over and over again.
And so when you look at the
actual evolution of the way
DVDs worked and the
way video tapes worked,
it was really the kids movies
that spawned the ownership
desire because people wanted
to see it over and over again
just like music.
Whereas other movies tend
to have this one time
is enough or two times is
enough, something of that sort.
Now I don't know how that plays
into the ultimate economic
structure of the
industry, but it's
a very different
characteristic of the media.
And I think that has something
to do with the answer
to your puzzle.
AUDIENCE: I think
along those lines,
there's actually
films that are made
for the mass audience
versus the ones that are
more like a literature thing.
And you want to go back to it
to enrich your experience of it
again and discover new things.
But I think as
far as what you're
saying on the quality
of the entertainment,
I think for every
"House of Cards,"
you also have a "Full House."
You have a "Marco Polo."
You have quite a few things
that are immediately tossable.
MICHAEL SMITH: Are
those positive examples
or negative examples?
AUDIENCE: I think they're
quite negative, actually.
And a lot of it, you have data.
You say that the people like
these different plot points.
They like these
different elements.
Those incorporate into a story.
You've had this since
the Roger Corman days.
You want your prison
film with the girl fight,
with the guns and everything.
And you make whatever you want--
MICHAEL SMITH: Speak for
yourself, but go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
You have that.
Even there's a book
from a couple years ago
that was talking about
scripts for big budget films,
"The Dark Knight" and the
second Star Trek movie
were made from the same thing.
One had a good execution,
one not so good.
People didn't respond to it.
They do the same plot points
at the same beats in the movie.
If you time them,
they're roughly a bad guy
gets captured, bad
guy gets let go.
They're doing these things
at the exact same times,
except one does it well,
one doesn't do it so well.
So there is artistry to allow
for with the data points.
MICHAEL SMITH: No, no, no.
And again, we're not claiming
that the artistry goes away.
I think all we're claiming
is that you can do things
profitably in an on-demand
platform that wouldn't be
profitable in a la carte sales.
But go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Sure, but
along those lines,
are you also
considering the fact
that for the television
environment, the theater
environment you
have to allot time
for the next showing, the
commercials, the trailers.
Online, you don't
have to do that.
So it's also allowing
for a longer time
to tell a story can
make those better
stories even more better.
But the garbage shows,
they kind of just
stick around a
little bit longer.
MICHAEL SMITH: Again, I
would go back to the notion
that-- you are absolutely right.
In a world where I
don't have commercials,
in a world where I
don't have to wait
a week to see the next
episode, I can do stuff.
I can make stuff work that
wouldn't work in broadcast.
To me, "Arrested Development"
is the classic example of this.
If you fell into
"Arrested Development"
season 3, episode 5, you would
have no idea what's going on.
The show only makes sense if you
can go back and get caught up.
"Stranger Things"
is another example.
It makes sense because
you can binge it.
So it's not, in a
sense, that Hollywood
lost their creative mojo.
It's just that, again, the
new on-demand platforms
allow you to do stuff
that you just couldn't do
in a traditional broadcast way.
But execution, creativity is
absolutely still important.
There's no doubt about that.
Did that sort of
answer your question?
MICHAEL SMITH: Do you
want to jump in on this?
RAHUL TELANG: I'm just
saying just because you
have data doesn't
mean that you'll
end up making better shows.
I mean, at some
level, the talent that
is available to the Netflix
in terms of creative
is the same talent,
to an extent,
available to sometimes
the large Hollywood
studio, except that
maybe Netflix has
these other advantages,
that is it doesn't have
to be a linear story from
9:00 to 9:45, take a break,
then come back.
Whereas in the Netflix, you
could have 20 hours of show
in mind versus a
chunk of 45 minutes.
That also probably makes
it more enriching, maybe,
to the creator if you
have, again, people who
can make good stories.
Of course, I mean, if
you have poor execution,
it doesn't matter what you have.
So, as I said, in baseball, if
you have access to good data,
it doesn't mean that you
can make a better picture.
The picture is still going
to be the same picture.
But if you have
access to good data,
maybe you can
identify the talent
and then nurture the talent
and then promote and support
that talent, I think.
MICHAEL SMITH: Maybe
another way to describe
this is, why did
Netflix sign Adam
Sandler to a five-movie deal?
And why did Amazon
sign Woody Allen
to write a television show?
I think you could make an
argument that both Adam Sandler
and Woody Allen are niche
tastes, acquired tastes.
So why might they work
for Netflix and Amazon
not for anybody in the
traditional industry?
Because Netflix and Amazon know
exactly who the Woody Allen
fans are and exactly-- I'll
point at Hal-- exactly who
the Adam Sandler fans are.
And they can promote
that content to them
much more efficiently.
And at least by all
public announcements,
Netflix is arguing that its
Adam Sandler creations have been
a huge hit for the platform.
AUDIENCE: So, I guess,
what do you think
about the recommendation
systems and the black hole
sort of thing, where I
discover you like peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches,
so I'm going
to give you all these variants
of peanut butter and jelly.
You don't like peanut
butter and jelly anymore
because I inundated you with
peanut butter and jelly.
What do you think is the danger
there with data-based story
telling?
RAHUL TELANG: So I'll
give one quick example.
I was reading--
actually, a reporter
was asking me about it,
so it came to my mind.
So apparently Spotify runs--
I am not a Spotify subscriber,
so I don't know all the
details, but Spotify
has this-- what-- Discover
Playlist or something?
MICHAEL SMITH: Yeah.
RAHUL TELANG: So, apparently,
this Discover Playlist
on Spotify is widely popular.
People love the
Discover Playlist.
And I was actually reading
a little bit about it.
What it is-- and it was nothing
but a recommendation system
to figure out what
songs people love.
And this, to my-- I guess
I shouldn't be surprised,
I'm from Carnegie Mellon--
the recommendation system is
basically built on
this deep machine
learning, the deep learning
theory of machine learning.
And I said, could it offer
you a bad recommendation?
Of course, it could offer
you a bad recommendation.
But it seems like our
data analytics is getting
more and more sophisticated.
And new ones that,
more likely than not,
it is actually going to delight
users rather than disappoint
users.
Even with our
recommendation engine,
human recommendations also
have significant amount
of bad hit rate.
So at some level, we're
comparing the world
before the engine versus after
these engines came about.
And I actually feel that most of
the people are actually happy.
And they'll get even
better with time
rather than relying on human
curators who are probably as
crappy as we expect them to be.
MICHAEL SMITH: Well,
I would actually use--
and hopefully this won't
be pandering to anybody
in the audience-- but
my favorite example I
use in class is just to take a
screenshot of my YouTube front
page.
You've got Rolling Stones clips.
You've got baseball highlights.
You've got "West
Wing" episode clips.
I mean, you guys do
an amazingly good job
of presenting me with
16 different clips
that I can easily waste 45
minutes on just exploring
around.
And I think being
able to say, here
are a bunch of
recommendations, it
looks like Mike isn't
clicking on the peanut butter
and jelly ones as
much as he once
did, let's transition to
something new, I think
is actually pretty
darn powerful.
And I think you guys actually do
an amazingly good job at that.
And thank you.
AUDIENCE: He's discovered
his Google profile.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL SMITH: Yeah, exactly.
Question from a former student.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MICHAEL SMITH: I hear you.
AUDIENCE: I studied
[INAUDIBLE] so I
like to ask you a question.
So it seems like there's
some sort of a war going on,
like a battle going on between
the incumbent entertainment
players versus the ones that
are already established.
Who do you think
is going to win?
Or where do you think
is the stabilization
point between this?
MICHAEL SMITH: You
want to take this one?
RAHUL TELANG: I don't know
if there's a war going on,
but I would say that the
traditional players are not
used to an entry from basically
a technology start-up who
used to be just a distributor.
I mean, it was a
DVD distributor--
that's what Netflix
was-- and then became
a distributor for streaming.
And now it realized
that it can actually
do a pretty good job
of creating content
and just make vertically
integrated, all in one shop.
Now who is going to win?
The ground fact is that I
think some of the things
that we mention
in the book, that
is having access to audience,
having this huge customer base,
having ability to
identify their interests,
I think they are going to play
an increasingly important role
in giving you a
competitive advantage.
Could the traditional players
be able to acquire those?
Of course.
I mean, they have
deep experience
in building very good
content as you meant.
They make those
interesting stories.
They have access to some
of their own platform.
They can actually
negotiate quite hard.
I think one other thing that
we didn't have enough time
to talk about is that a lot
of these online platforms
actually share no
data with them.
Some [INAUDIBLE]
because it never
occurred to them that
they should actually
ask for that data.
They don't have the
right sort of skills.
But I think there is a
possibility that maybe it
will go in that direction where
these companies will also say,
I can also use some of these
skills that these forms have
and build some of that
into my business model.
So I don't know who is
going to be the winner.
Maybe there are going
to be some mergers.
Who knows?
I mean, that's
really harder to say.
Maybe Mike can look in
the future better than I.
MICHAEL SMITH: No, I was going
to say something very similar.
Going back to "The
Perfect Storm" analogy,
we all know how the book ends.
Well, I won't spoil it for you.
I think we're not saying
that's the preordained outcome
for the traditional
people in the industry.
In fact, in Hollywood,
it would be really cool
if they had an independent
digital distribution
platform that received funding
from the studios that created--
and hopefully by
now you've picked up
that I'm talking about Hulu.
RAHUL TELANG: Gee.
MICHAEL SMITH: I
think they actually
have some pretty
interesting assets
they can bring to bear on this.
So who wins?
I don't know.
But I think this is a
very interesting battle.
I don't think it's obvious one
side wins and the other side
loses.
In the end, I think
consumers win.
And that's the dog
slide at the end.
AUDIENCE: Just a
follow-up question.
Have you heard back from
any of your counterparts
in the industry about what
their reaction to the book is?
And do they feel threatened?
Do they feel excited about
the changes there are?
MICHAEL SMITH: Depends
on who you ask.
RAHUL TELANG: That's right.
MICHAEL SMITH: I will
say we've presented this
to three of the six studios.
And we're presenting
to two more tomorrow.
And in fact, we've received
really good feedback
on what we're
saying in the book.
I think they're much more
receptive to this message
than a lot of people outside
the industry would suspect.
I think the other
thing that we've
recognized working
with the studios,
that the studios are not
monolithic in any sense.
If you ask five people
in a studio what
they think their digital
strategy ought to be,
you're going to get
seven different answers.
There is a strong debate within
the entertainment industry
today, internally, about
what should we be doing.
And again, a big
part of the reason
we wanted to write
this book is we
wanted to give a different
perspective on why
this is something where
you should move right now.
RAHUL TELANG: When you get a
speaker from Amazon and Google
come and talk in the
class in the university,
every time you hear
is that every decision
is done made from data.
No matter how trivial
the decision is,
we are going to
do an A/B testing.
We are going to do this.
We are going to do that.
And then you move
into this world
where a lot of these
decisions are actually
not based on serious data.
It's based on this
is how we did things.
This is how things work.
That culture, I think,
probably will change.
I think increasingly
the firms, they're
already realizing just hiring
the right sort of talent
and making sure that the data--
it's a lot of cultural change.
I'm pretty sure that that
change will take place.
Well, whether that's
going to be enough or not
is anybody's guess.
AUDIENCE: So you
could phrase the thing
that Rahul was talking
earlier about the distribution
being a really inefficient
thing, that then we
had technology that could
overcome that, technology that
could give a better product.
There's a gap that
existed there.
There's a gap between what was
possible and what was provided.
Do you see there's still a gap?
Have we gotten as
far as we can go?
Or are there other-- rather
than just-- are we just
tipping the balance
further from here
on in of the same kind of stuff?
Or is there something
different to come?
Is there still a gap
between what we can do now
and what is happening?
RAHUL TELANG: So did you mean
in terms of distribution?
I wasn't clear.
AUDIENCE: I was generalizing
from distribution
in terms of anything
that's possible now.
Is there still things
that technology
can do that the movie
industry hasn't leveraged,
that Netflix doesn't do.
Netflix has to go into
a new way of dealing
that it doesn't do yet.
MICHAEL SMITH: I know
the answer is yes.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHAEL SMITH: I mean--
AUDIENCE: Can you see a gap?
Can you see anything
that you're like,
oh, I wish they
would fix that or--
RAHUL TELANG: I feel
like the technology--
there's one aspect, whether
the technology makes
a lot of things possible.
What the challenge
comes is what is
the business model
behind the technology
that I can make money?
I mean, technology
makes it possible
that I can make the movie
available on streaming
platform on day one.
There is enough
bandwidth available.
There is enough storage
available, all the devices.
That's possible.
But there is no
business model that
will allow the firms to say,
can I profitably do that
so that I can actually
recover my investment back?
So the engineers will keep
developing all of these--
how to distribute better, how
to distribute more efficiently,
how to lower the
cost of production.
But then can we have the
business model that allows--
AUDIENCE: That's kind
of like more faster.
And that'll keep happening.
Is that the--
RAHUL TELANG:
Cheaper and faster.
AUDIENCE: Cheaper, faster.
RAHUL TELANG: I think that,
for sure, but as I said,
what is the business
model on the top of it?
AUDIENCE: I guess
the transformation
is that we don't watch the
TV show on the first day it
comes out anymore.
I started "House of Cards"
probably four months
after the first release because
I just didn't get around to it.
And then I watched
the whole thing.
That's like a change in
the style of consuming.
Is there more style changes?
Or is it just more faster then?
MICHAEL SMITH: No,
I think there are
plenty of really interesting
style changes just like that.
that the audience can
watch it in different ways.
And that enables
the storytellers
to tell different stories
that wouldn't have worked.
And there's this
wonderful feedback loop
of all sorts of really
cool innovation.
I think the other thing we're
seeing is a shift from, again,
when channels are scarce you've
got to have a system that says,
I'm going to choose what gets
made before it gets made.
I'm going to have
this choke point.
It's not arbitrary.
It's that I can only distribute
a certain amount of stuff.
So somebody's got to choose.
One of the wonderful
things about having
an abundance in
distribution is that you
can let everything get made
and then on the back end
see what works.
My daughter loves watching
videos of other people playing
Minecraft on YouTube.
It's not obvious that's
a good idea-- ex-ante.
But it clearly delivers
a lot of value for her.
And that's OK.
As economists we don't judge.
AUDIENCE: But as a parent.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL SMITH: Fair point.
RAHUL TELANG: He said, who
is going to be the winner?
I mean, if you look at Netflix,
because of the technology,
it's easier for them to be
able to offer these shows
where you can do binge watch.
On a television, that's
just much harder to do that.
Now the Netflix of this worlds
are also changing expectations
from people about what is
the demand in the content?
Now you ask a 21-year-old
or 18-year-old,
I mean, for them,
this idea that I'm
going to watch an
episode from 9:00 to 9:45
every Thursday, that
just doesn't, I think,
appeal to them.
They want it when they want
it at their convenience,
maybe watch the whole thing.
And now you can see that
the Netflix platform
offers that opportunity.
It gives them that
feature that, again,
a linear television probably
doesn't give them a feature.
So if they have to
choose between the two,
they say, well, then I would
become a Netflix customer
because Netflix gives me this
tremendous flexibility that I
can't get on my Comcast
cable connection,
for example, at least right now.
So I think that's another
element to this competition.
AUDIENCE: Last question.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I guess building on
his thing is, well,
actually a number of
years ago, my wife
found this film that was
like audience participation,
choose your own
adventure thing where
the audience voted where they
wanted the next scene to go.
So why aren't
technology companies
doing that type of thing
with their platforms?
They seem to have the
ability to do that.
You're tapped into
everybody's UIs.
You can say, I want the
next branch to go this way.
I want the next
branch to go that way.
AUDIENCE: They're called games.
RAHUL TELANG: What?
MICHAEL SMITH: Well,
actually, I was
going in a different direction.
I was thinking "Epic
Rap Battles of History."
Have you have you seen this?
AUDIENCE: Well, you
can vote, like who won.
MICHAEL SMITH: You can vote.
AUDIENCE: But you don't, really,
at least from my experience,
I don't think you chain on
to the next and follow that.
Or do you?
MICHAEL SMITH: That's fair.
That might be the next thing.
RAHUL TELANG: I forget now.
It escapes me.
Wasn't there an ABC
show which actually had
people can send their
stories and that--
MICHAEL SMITH: Yeah.
RAHUL TELANG: And I
think-- I forget it--
I think it actually
got entangled
into some sort of
a copyright issue
where I think the Writers
Association or something said
you can't really have people
who are not part of the Writers
Association send the stories
that become part of the net.
So I'm blanking
on it, but I think
I had this weird angle to this
whole user-generated content
going back into the show.
There was this somewhat
of a bizarre friction.
And then I think the whole show
then eventually got canceled,
I believe.
I forget.
MICHAEL SMITH: It was
"In the Motherhood."
It was this series
a webisodes where
parents would write in their
most embarrassing child
stories.
And then they would create
a webisode around this.
And I forgot who bought it.
I think it was ABC--
RAHUL TELANG: Yeah,
something like that.
MICHAEL SMITH:
--bought the rights.
And then as soon as people
started sending in their ideas,
the Writers Guild came
in and said, that's fine,
but you've got to pay each
idea that comes in $1,000
because that's the Guild
minimum for writing.
So, again, all
that to say there's
a lot of existing
structures that
get in the way of innovation.
But there's also a
whole lot of value
you could create by doing
some of these innovations.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
RAHUL TELANG: Thank you.
MICHAEL SMITH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]